so as you might have noticed by now on
this show I really love making childish
jokes I love making dirty jokes I really
do but obviously I also like talking
about weird trippy things so to offset
all those dirty jokes I'd like to invite
one some of my smarter and wise or
friends to come on the show occasionally
and talk about meaningful things it's a
segment we call profound profane
so obviously I will provide the profane
part but for the profound please say
hello to my friend live in studio Duncan
Trussell
sure sure ah sorry oh thank you yes sir
can't believe you put me on TV can we
make it a little more profound in here
all right
Terence Mckenna once said are actually a
mushroom told Terence Mckenna the nature
loves courage you make the commitment
and nature will respond to that
commitment by removing impossible
obstacles dream the impossible dream and
the world will not grind you under it
will lift you up this is the trick this
is the shamanic dance in the waterfall
whatever that means look this is how
magic is done by hurling yourself into
the abyss and discovering it's a feather
bed as a man to feel the most pleasure
you have to make a mess
imagine that ladies if every time you
listen to your favorite song when it's
over you had to pour salad dressing on
your lap